BUT IN DOING SO CHINA WOULD BE
HARMING THE VERY MARKET IT
NEEDS.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN CRITICAL FOR US ON TO
TESTIFY ON CAPITOL HILL, HERE'S
WHAT HE TOLD REPORTERS TODAY.
>> MY SON SPENT I GUESS OVER 20
HOURS TESTIFYING ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT MUELLER SAID WAS 100% OKAY
NOW THEY WANT HIM TO TESTIFY
AGAIN, I DON'T KNOW WHY.
IT SEEMS VERY UNFAIR TO ME.
>> Bret: THERE WAS A SUBPOENA
AND NOW A CHANGE OF PLANS.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND
DONALD TRUMP JR. HAVE COME TO AN
ACCOMMODATION THAT YOU WILL COME
BACK FOR MORE TESTIMONY SOMETIME
IN JUNE.
DONALD TRUMP JR. HAD A LETTER
READY TO GO TO SEND TO THE
COMMITTEE SAYING, HE WAS NOT
GOING TO COME UP AND ENOUGH WAS
ENOUGH AND HE WAS NOT GOING TO
GO THROUGH THIS AGAIN, BASICALLY
DARING THEM TO HOLD HIM IN
CONTEMPT.
THE COMMITTEE SAID WE DON'T WANT
TO DO THIS, CAN WE WORK THIS
OUT?
FOR THE FIRST TIME THEY AGREED
TO WHAT HE HAD BEEN ASKING AND
THAT IS A RETURN ENGAGEMENT
LIMITED TIME AND SCOPE, ONE TO
TWO HOURS WITH LIMITED
FOLLOW-UP.
THEY SAID ALL KINDS OF THINGS IN
THIS LETTER INCLUDING THE
TESTIMONY, IT HAD BEEN CITED IN
THE MUELLER REPORT ON THE FACT